Hey youtubers it’s charlie, since we’ve
all had a chance to process the walking dead
midseason finale I thought it was time to
start talking about wtf is going to happen
in the second half of the season.
Aside from everyone dying horribly game of
thrones style.
This video will be my top 10 predictions for
the second half of the season.
Since it won’t be back for about 8 more
weeks I’ll be doing weekly bonus videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
And let me know in the comments what you want
to talk about most.
So in the name of sweet baby judith let’s
get this walker part started
Number 10 - Direct Comic Book Adaptations.
Robert Kirkman said that the mid-season premiere
in february will be the most faithful adaptation
of the comic book story.
If you have read the story following the governor’s
death try not to spoil it too much in the
comments.
The story will pick up right where it left
off just like last year.
Number 9 - The fate of baby judith.
I saw an overwhelming amount of comments about
judth being dead, but if you look closely
at her bloody carseat it is unbuckled.
And walkers would have just eaten her out.
This means she’s definitely alive, but of
all the people who could have grabbed her,
it’s most likely that tyreese and Lizzie’s
group took her and ran into the woods.
I almost feel like it would have been unforgivable
to have killed judith in episode 8.
But let me know yes or no if you would have
quit the show if they definitely killed her.
Number 8 - Sheriff Carl.
When I say sheriff carl what I mean is that
Carl not only gets more scenes, he also becomes
more of a leader.
And it’s mostly out of necessity.
If you just watch Rick during the last half
of episode 8 you’re forced to just watch
him slowly die inside.
In the teaser for episode 9 you can even see
that he’s gotten the shit kicked out of
him emotionally and physically so much that
Carl basically has to take care of him.
Number 7 - New Characters.
some new characters from the comic books that
we’ve already seen casting calls for are
Eugene, Rosita and Abraham.
Most of them won’t arrive until episode
10.
in the comics they were introduced back on
hershel’s farm, but remember it got burned
down in season 2, so the people that escaped
from the prison will meet them en route to
Washington DC.
The cool thing is that Abraham’s group will
get a full backstory in their own episode,
just like the governor got his own episode
to explain where he’d been.
Number 6 - New Splinter Groups.
There will be several separate storylines
featuring different groups with members from
the governor’s camp and the prison.
There were a lot of good people living with
the governor like Lilly and Tara that will
now be traveling with people from the prison.
We don’t know who will mix into which groups,
but remember right now there’s the group
that escaped on the bus and at least two different
groups that escaped into the woods on foot.
One was Tyreese and the girls and the other
was led by Rick and Carl.
It would be fairly poetic if Lilly and tara
ended up with Rick’s group.
Number 5 - The return of Morgan.
Scott Gimple said that Morgan would be coming
back and in the comics Rick and Abraham run
into him back in Rick’s hometown on their
way to washington DC.
Number 4 - The return of carol.
It took morgan almost two seasons to come
back after he split from Rick, but TVGuide
was reporting that she’d rejoin Daryl’s
group before the end of the season.
So it’s unlikely that we’ll see her right
away when the show comes back.
Number 3 - New Unknown character named Gareth.
He’ll be an amalgam of some unknown characters
from the comics but Hollywood reporter was
saying he’d play a big role in season 4.
The best guesses right now is that he either
has something to do with the Alexandria Safe-Zone
and Abraham’s group or he’s a version
of Chris, the leader of the hunters.
Number 2 - The hunters are coming.
The cannibals are just around the corner.
It’s unclear whether or not they’ll just
be teased or if we’ll actually see them
this season.
In the comics they battle with Rick’s group
while they’re on their way to washington
DC.
So meeting them will largely depend on how
far Rick’s group travels before the season
finale.
and my number 1 thing to look forward to - The
Sanctuary and The Alexandria Safe Zone.
Remember the radio message Daryl’s group
heard before they had to abandon the charger.
A lot of you guys have predicted that we’ll
go back to the alexandria safe zone, so it
could have been from there.
Or it could just be a trap.
There are some new villains from the comics
that we haven’t met yet not including the
hunters.
I don’t want to spoil it too much for anyone
that hasn’t read the comics, but it seems
too early in the story to meet them.
Let me know what you’re most excited to
see when walking dead comes back and do you
think we’ll meet the hunters this season?
Like I said, I’ll be doing bonus walking
dead videos for the next 8 weeks.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
And be sure to let me know what kind of videos
you want me to do.
Right now click here to watch my mid-season
finale video and click here to for my videos
for the rest of season 4.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow,
high fives!